دفعه لندن يردون على النقد وهشام عاشور
صعيدي لاول مره في عمله نادره ومن جوي
اوردز لسطار لمن هو ولدنا رقم اثنين
ابراهيم الحجاج من نجاح لنجاح و طبيب محمد
فؤاد يتهم رامز جلال باتهام خطير ثم
يتراجع اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
من اكثر الاعمال الرمضانيه اللي محيط فيها
جدل وكلام هو مسلسل دفعه لندن اللي في نفس
الوقت محقق نجاح جماهيري ومتابعه كبيره
جدا المسلسل بيتكلم عن مجموعه من طلبه
الجامعه من مختلف الجنسيات بيختاروا
الدراسه وكل واحد فيهم حامل افكار
ومعتقداته رسائل مختلفه عن الاخر دفعت
لندن هو ثالث عمل دفعه للكاتبه هبه مشاري
حماده فسبقوا دفعه القاهره ودفعه بيروت
واللي كمان احاطهم برضو كثير جدل دفعت
لندن من اولى حلقاته محط جدل هو كمان سواء
من تعليقات على جراه في الطرح والكرام
مرورا باحداث اعتبرها ناس غير منطقيه مثل
انه الاميره ديانا لجات لطلاب كويتيين في
مره كذا وهي هربانه من نهايه بالجدل
الاكبر هو الاتهامات بالاساءه للعراقيين
والسبب انه في المسلسل فيه شخصيه عراقيه
تطلب تشتغل انه كعاملات في منازل او في
منزل
الكويتيين وبتتهم بالسرقه
واتباعا شفنا الساعات الماضيه صناع دفعه
لندن بيطلعوا بيردوا فكاتبه العمل هيبه
مشاري حماده ردت على احد منتقدي العمل على
انستجرام وقالت انه تاريخ العراق اكبر من
انه يخبرها عنه المشحونين عاطفيا وقصيري
النظر اللي ما في فكرهم الا مخ المؤامره
وقالت انه اللي بيتابع العمل بيشوف انه
الفتاه العراقيه اللي بتعمل كعامله او
خادمه كانت ابنه الاستاذ تاريخ تم اعدامه
وصديقه اللي امنوا على بناته اللي عندهم
ثروه كبيره سرقهم وتركهم من دون اي شيء
وقالت انه الهدف هو اسقاط سرقه العراق من
العراقيين وسرقه تاريخها ومستقبل ابنائها
بسبب الحرب والخلافات وقالت انه الغيره
والحماس اخذت الناس اللي بعيد وانها بتغار
على تاريخ وفكر العراق اكثر من اي احد
ليلى عبد الله وهي ايضا احدى نجمات العمل
طلعت وردت هي كمان في مقطع فيديو وردها
تحديدا قالت له يعني انه تحديدا على
منتقديه كلمه قالتها احدى شخصيات المسلسل
واعتبروها الناس جريئه
ليش دائما احنا يعني مثلا احنا اغراضنا
اغراض بنات ما يصير نقول حرام عيب كل شيء
بالخشوه كل شيء يعني ما ينقال انا اشوف ما
ادري انا اشوفه مبالغه بالنفاق صراحه يعني
انا كل مره قاعد اشوف نفاق زياده وزياده
انا بالنسبه ليك يا ليلى انا قاعد برا
الحق ولا احد انا بالنسبه لك ليلى انا احس
انه انه اعيد مو تبرير حق ولا حد انا احس
ان الكلمه ما فيها شيء اللي مسوينها على
دفعه لندن اللي قماشه راف محمد شلون قالت
الكلمه هذه انا ما اشوف انه فيها شيء غلط
اغراض البنات اغراضنا احنا كلنا
مو موعد
ولا حرام
انا اشوف انه هذا شيء عادي
يعني
بدي اقول عن القضيه الثانيه
لكن ان شاء الله كل شيء بوقتها حلو يعني
كل شيء يعني بسولف عنه بس كل شيء بوقتها
حلو
العاده الاعلاميه عراقيه شفناها بتقتحم
عالم التمثيل السنه الماضيه في مسلسل
الوطن وهذه السنه هي واحده من بطلات دفعه
لندن وحقيقه عامله دور فاجئ كثيرين
والتعليقات عليه ماليه المنصات اهلا فيك
معنا يا رولا طبعا كل عام وانت بالف خير
ومبروك كل هذه الضجه
والشغل اللي عاملينه
وانت بالف خير وشكرا ينعاد عليكم بالخير
والبركه يا رب علينا وعليك طبعا وعلى
الجميع ان شاء الله رولا خليني ابتدي
اتكلم معاك اول شيء يعني قبل ما ندخل في
موضوع انه الجدل وما الجدل والكلام ده كله
دفعه لندن تحديدا ايش اللي جذبك له
شوفي ساره انا من زمان يعني دفعات دفعات
بيروت دفعات القاهره كانت قريبه على قلبي
من ناحيتين اولا لانه انا درست بلندن
وعاشت فتره انه يكون عندك اصحاب من كل
البلدان تعيشوا مع بعض اكشن والتعرف على
بعض تعرف على على عادات وتقاليد بعض فحسيت
فيها هذا الرابط المعنوي بيني وبين
الدفعات
تشاركي بس يعني مين اللي اقترح اسمك كيف
جات مشاركتك في هذا الموضوع
شوفي هو يعني بعد ما شاركت السنه اللي
فاتت بوطن كان دائما عندي اكيد يعني كنتوا
عارفيني من ايام
صباح الخير يا عرب برامج
فدائما كنت احب انه لما اعمل شيء لازم
اسوي صح فخلال فتره بعد مشاركه برمضان
الفارقه لا خليني اشتغل على شي انه خليني
اطور نفسي خليني اعرف الطريقه اللي انا
ماشيه فيها فسبحان الله يعني بدات الامور
تيجي لوحدها ودائما يقول لك هذا اللوف
اتراكشن تصير لما انت يعني صار عندك ثقه
انه شي حلو راح يصير وصارت قانون الجذب
يعني انجذبتي لهذا المجال
وصار الموضوع
حسب ما سمعت استاذه هبه هي كانت من اول
المرشح
للاسمي اني اكون بهذا العمل طيب يعني رولا
كمان في نفس الوقت العمل عامل مشاهده
كبيره جدا بصراحه يعني في الارقام نحن
عارفين العمل عامل مشاهده ولكن في نفس
الوقت صار في هجوم كبير وتحديدا يعني
خلينا من الهجوم طبعا مثلا على الكاتبه
على الفنانين اخرين والكلام ده كله اوكي
خلينا نتكلم تحديدا على الهجوم اللي صار
عليك انت واجهتي هجوم قاسي جدا لاي درجه
ازعجك هذا الهجوم
هذه اول حلقه يعني طيب خلينا نستنى خلينا
نشوف شو راح يصير بعدين انه شفنا انه
السوشل ميديا اخدت
مدى بعيد غير ما كان لازم يكون متوقع يعني
اوكي ممكن احنا نعطي راي ممكن وانا احترم
من رايي ان كان سلبي او ايجابي يعني هذا
اكيد وكلنا متفقين عليه لكن انك تعطي راي
او تحكم وتقيم فقط من اول حلقه حسينا انه
هذا شوي كان الموضوع سابق لاوانه هذا اولا
وثاني شيء انه احنا حتى كممثلين او
مشاركين بالعمل ما في حد منا يقبل انه اي
امراه
بعد ما نقول عراقيه او غيرها اي امراه
تتعرض للاساء ثم بالك انك انا عراقيه اقبل
على هذا الشيء
الورق في البدايه ما حسيت انه في اي مشكله
في الشخصيات
كان في اسئله طبعا عشان تعرفي الاستاذه
هبه تكتب بطريقه مختلفه تماما عن باقي
اللايس الدراميه اللي متعودين عليها واللي
نشوفها يعني نحتاج نقرا مره ومرتين وثلاثه
فعلا نفهم هالحبكه وما حسيتي للحظه انه لا
ممكن الموضوع ينفهم غلط انه ليش ليش
العراقيات طالعين في كدور عاملات في عند
مثلا كويتيات
امانه ما كان الموضوع مركز على هذا الجزء
يعني لما تقرا النص ما كان مركز عليه
واصلا احنا لما سالنا الاسئله ولما تكلمنا
مع الاستاذه هبه ولا مش تكلمنا مع الورشه
العامله بالموضوع
توضحت كثير الامور طبعا انا مو حابه احرق
احداث العمل لا بس كل هذا الاشياء اللي
اللي شفتوها كلها راح تتوضح بالحلقات
الجايه
وضعهم للبنات والكلام هذا كله
تمام مع انه ساره في بدايه الحلقه وهذا
الشيء اللي احنا نعيده ونكررها وسبق وكثير
من زملائي من
كادر العمل انه كان في يعني
سبب ليش اطفال في سن معين لقوا نفسهم في
لندن في شخص خان الامانه ما ذكرنا اي شيء
له علاقه باي شخص او اي يعني اي شيء كان
واضح صح يا رولا يعني العراقيين العراقيين
قالوا انه رولاكا عراقيه كان لازم ترفض
هذا الدور
شوفي احنا قاعدين نتكلم يعني شو سبب رفض
الدور يعني انتم حكمتوا على
شيء من اول حلقه طيب انا لو انا شفت في
شيء سيء او في شيء سيء لالي كممثله
اوك كعراقيه هل من المنطق والناس تعرفني
من زمان هل من المنطق اني انا اقبل شيء
يضرني ويضر اسمي ويضر مشواري ويضر الناس
كيف تعرفني فلهذا السبب قلنا من اول يوم
ومن حتى قبل نزل من مسلسل الذكر اول لقاء
عملناه هذا العمل يحتاج التاني والصبر
فعلا الحب كان موجود فيه مفاجات
التهديد يا رولا
لا الحمد لله لا شوفي يعني احنا يعني
اتوقع كل الدول العربيه الموضوع يمثل
المراه او يمس حد
شوي تطلع هذه المشاعر زادت على زوم احنا
كلنا متفاهمين هذا الشيء بس لهذا السبب
نقول يعني صبروا علينا شويه والله العظيم
يعني
التفاعل مثل ما كان في تفاعل ساره شوي كان
قاسي
هذا التفاعل كان في تفاعل جدا رائع
وبتوصلنا احيانا اشياء جدا جميله بس بنفس
الوقت حابين انه الكل يتفهم القصه يعني
على العموم انتم مع الجدل هذا انتم
متصدرين المشاهده يعني ما في جدال في هذا
الموضوع يعني فعلى العموم نحن طبعا بنتمنى
لك التوفيق وزي ما قلتي حنستمر في
المتابعه وحنشوف رولا كل التوفيق لك صراحه
في كل اعمالك القادمه انت جميله عزيزه
يعني واكيد بنتمنى لك التوفيق ونشوفك ان
شاء الله لما ترجع على دبي كانت معنا
الممثله رولا عادل شكرا لك
تناولنا في حلقتنا امس الجدل اللي صاير
حول المسلسل التاريخي رساله الامام اللي
بيتكلم عن اخر ست سنوات في حياه الامام
الشافعي رحمه الله لي كان قضاها في مصر
الجدل كان عن عده اخطاء تاريخيه مثل ما
سماها المنتقدين بدءا من استعانه الايمان
بطبيب يعني مسيحي لعلاج زوجته وانتهاء
بحديث الشافعي باللهجه العاميه وكان من
ضمن الانتقادات تداول صور كمان لخالد
النبوي بنضاره قيل انها من العمل وقيل انه
انها خطا لانه شكل النظاره مودرن وكمان
انه الشافعين ما كان بيلبس نظاره من اليوم
ظهرت حقيقه الصوره اللي اتضح فيها انها من
كواليس المسلسل واول من نشرها كانت حسابات
قناه الحياه العارضه للمسلسل واما الجدل
الاحدث كمان فهو اكبر من كده ففي شاعر
سوري اسمه حذيفه الناس بتغريده شارك فيها
ابيات بياديها الفنان خالد النبوي اللي
بيقوم بدور الامام الشافعي وقال انه الشعر
هذا له هو مو للشافعي والابيات هي هذه
اللي جالسين بتشوفوها امامكم الان وكانت
ضمن مشهد من مشاهد رساله الامام ونسبت له
اللي سمعتوها جايه للشاعر انه اصدقائه
بيرسلوها له انه هذه الابيات مول الشافعي
لا انها هي هذه الابيات له وهو كتبها من
عشر سنوات وانه هو كان من زمان وضح الجدل
حول البيتين اللي الناس بتنسبهم للشافعي
بس في الحقيقه الابيات اللي هو وقال انه
الامام اكبر من كل قول ينسب اليه حتى لو
كان شعره هو شخصيا ووصف اللي صار في
المسلسل بالجهل الفظيع بالامام رحمه الله
وبلغته الشعريه بالتحديد وقال انه اذا
يعني
تفصيله مثل هذه ما انتبهوا لها فتخيلوا
حجم الكوارث الاخرى الشاعر صعد اكثر من
كذا وشكك في انه اصلا في احد قرا او في
احد من صنع العمل قرا سيره الشافعي اصلا
وعلى فكره بالبحث في صفحه الشاعره الشخصيه
على فيسبوك موجوده الابيات ببوست ناشره من
تسع سنوات وكمان موقع الديوان المتخصص في
الشعر واللي بيضم اكثر من 11 الف قصيده
لاكثر من الف شاعر موثق الابيات باسم
الشاعر السوري كمان
كمان خلينا نضيف على التطورات اللي صايره
في الجدل اللي صاير حول رساله الامام
تنويه اتفاجئ فيه المشاهدين في اول الحلقه
السادسه ما كان موجود من قبل وبيقول
التنويه انه العمل رؤيه دراميه مستوحاه من
احداث تاريخيه وانه بعض حكايات العمل من
خيال المؤلف للضروره الدراميه ناس كثير
اعتبرت التنويه هذا اعتراف غير مباشر من
الصناع بالاخطاء ومحاوله للهروب وايجاد
مخرج من الجدل والانتقادات
مسلسل عمله نادره دراما مصريه صعيديه فيها
منافسه على السلطه والثروه وصراع بين
عائلتين بسبب زواج بيصير بين طرفين
والمسلسل من بطوله نيللي كريم وجمال
سليمان ومجموعه من الفنانين الاخرين ومنهم
الفنان هشام عاشور هشام اللي عرفوا الناس
كلاعب رمضان الماضي بموهبه تمثيليه وشارك
في اكثر من عمل اللي هم يوتير مسلسل
يوتيرن ومسلسل الاحلام سعيده كمان السنه
هشام صعيدي في عمله نادره وبيلعب دور عصام
اللي بيحب بنت الحاج عبد الجبار اللي
بيقوم بدوره الفنان الكبير جمال سليمان
لكن قصه الحب هذه بشوبا مشاكل وصراعات
عائليه جسيم بنتعرف عليها حلقه بعد ثانيه
مسلسل عمله نادره مختلف تماما بالنسبه
لهشام فاولا لانه هذه المره اللي بيخوض
فيها تجربه دراما الصعيديه مثل ما قلنا
وثانيا لانه هذا اول عمل فني بيشوفوا
الجمهور وبيجمعوا مع زوجته الفنانين اللي
كريم هشام اللي اشتغلوا سوى مسلسل اسمه
روز وليلى عشر حلقات لكن لسه ما عرضوا
منتظر عرضه على منصه شاهد لكن بعد رمضان
على العموم احنا معنا من القاهره الفنان
هشام عاشور اهلا فيك معنا يا هشام كل عام
وانت بالف خير
وانتم طيبين ورمضان كريم عليكم وعلى
المسلمين في كل حته في العالم كل سنه
وانتم طيبين وانت طيب يا رب هشام خلاص
الان نقدر نقدر نقول انه الفنان هشام
الممثل هشام خلاص هذه صارت اسمك الوظيفي
الجديد او مهنتك
طبعا مئه في الميه خلاص يعني لاعب سكواش
سابقا وفنان حاليا
كل حاجه لها وقتها خلصت قصه وبقى لي فتره
مركز جامد في التمثيل الحمد لله طيب حلو
خلينا نبتدي بعمله نادره يعني صراحه
الواحد لسه بادئ يدخل السوق والكلام هذا
كله يعني تحدي كبير انك تلعب شيء في بيئه
صعيديه يعني
بصي هو طبعا هو من اصعب الحاجات يعني
الصعيدي ده يعني
مش اسهل حاجه يعني ولكن الحمد لله كان
معنا الاستاذ عبد النبي الهواري اخويا
الكبير يعني مصحح اللغه عمل معنا شغل
بصراحه كلنا غير عادي والناس بعد ما قرت
المسلسل وحثت بحلاوه المسلسل كله قرر ان
هو يركز ويدوس جامد قوي في موضوع اللغه
وبعد ما دخلنا المسلسل وشفنا الصعيدي عامل
ازاي حبيناه حب يعني غير عادي يعني مشاعر
الصعيدي فظيعه يعني
ايش تحس اكبر غير اللغه والاشعه دي كلها
ايش اكبر التحديات اللي حاسسها في هذه
الشخصيه يعني ليش حبيت انك تلعب هذه
الشخصيه تحديدا
بصي هي الشخصيه الوحيده اللي في المسلسل
يعني المفروض اللي هو الاستاذ المتعلم
اللي هو صوت الحق اللي هو صوت العقل في
وسط ناس كثيره جدا بتتخانق وبتتعارك على
على حاجات
يعني مش مش مهمه حاجات يعني مش قصدي مش
مهمه قصدي حاجات حاجات مش كويسه يعني
اتكلم على مخدرات وبنتكلم على سلاح
والاستاذ المتعلم محطوط في وسط دي ودي
حاجات بتحصل في الصعيد لما كنا في الصعيد
واحنا بنصور قعدنا كتير وسمعنا وشفنا ناس
كثيره جدا اهاليهم بيكبروهم وبيطلعوهم
بيعلموهم وبعدين بعد ما بيعلموهم بيلاقوا
نفسهم برده محطوطين في نفس القصه دي
محطوطين في النص في وسط مخدرات وفي وسط
سلاح وفي وسط حاجات كده وبيضطروا ان هم
يتعاملوا مع الموقف يعني كيف وجدت العمل
مع زوجتك طبعا النجمه الكبيره نيللي كريم
طبعا بنوجه لها تحيه بس يعني عاده مش سهل
الواحد يعني يشتغل مع يعني شريكه
والله نيللي دي وحش
ههه بصراحه عمل وحش تمثيل ما قصدك وحش
ثاني لان روح نورطك على الهوا يا هشام وما
ترجع البيت ههه
لا وحشه تمثيل طبعا واللي هي عملته ده
بصراحه يعني انا انا لحد لحد اسبوع قبل ما
نبدا ما كنتش يعني مصدق او شايف ان هي
تقدر تعمل حاجه زي كده لحد ما يعني ده
كاميرا
تحولت يعني انا كنت عارف طول عمري عارف ان
هي جامده جدا جدا جدا بس بعد اللي هي
عملته هنا وازاي ماسكه الشخصيه وازاي
ماسكه مشاعر الشخصيه الصعيدي والتون بتاع
اللغه
وتمثل بعنيها صعيدي وبتمثل بجسمها يعني
انا بصراحه شايف ان هي عامله دور هيبقى من
اكبر واهم الادوار بالنسبه لها واحنا ما
بنتقبلش كتير قوي في المسلسلتين مختلفين
بس يعني يعني تمام تمام بس بتشوفوا بعض في
الكواليس التصوير
بنشوف بعض الكواليس التصوير بس عايز اقول
لك يعني مسلسل يعني احنا اكثر عيلتنا
شغالين اكثر مع العيله بتاعتي مع استاذ
كمال ابو رقيه العظيم استاذ كمال ابو رياض
حبيبي
ومعانا طبعا استاذ احمد فهيم عبقري برضو
عامل جميل وميزو اللي هو محمد علي لازم
تشوفني عشان تفهم الصراع اللي داير بين
العوائل في المسلسل يعني دراما شديده طيب
بس اكيد هشام بتسمع الكلام حق انه هو
مفروض على المسلسل لانه زوج النجمه وما
الكلام ده كله بيزعجك الكلام ده
والله بصي هي القصه كلها بتبقى انت انت
عارفه انت مين ولا لا يعني انا بالنسبه لي
انا الحمد لله ذاكرت كتير جدا تمثيل في
امريكا وعملت حاجه صغيره فاليوت ايس تي في
وعارف انا امكانياتي كممثل
هذه نكته يمكن لازم توضحها هشام انك انت
موضوع التمثيل بادئ من 2013 في امريكا من
اصلا قبل ما تتزوج نيللي والكلام ده كله
اه طبعا انا ابتديت في
نيويورك 9 سنين وبعدين رحت
وذاكره المايستنيك كتير جدا سنه ونص في
الوقت بتاع الكورونا وانا كنت مستعد تماما
وبعدين لما جيت مصر قعدت ذاكرت طبعا عشان
مش مختلف بالعربي وكده وانا انا بالنسبه
لي قصه
انا انا بحب انا انا بعبد القصه دي انا
بعبدها لان انا بالنسبه لي ده فن التاثير
في البني ادم وانا بالنسبه لي التاثير في
البني ادم بالايجاب هو ده اللي بيشجيني
وده اللي انا ببقى دايما بدور عليه فانا
بشتغل على نفسي كل يوم بذاكر كل يوم
فيديوهات معينه عندي مدارس بشتغل معاه
عندي مدرس في مصر العصامي بشتغل معاه
فعندي حاجه انا شغال على نفسي كل يوم لان
انا عايز في الاخر ان انا بعمل الكلام ده
اروح هوليود ان شاء الله
ما بقدرش اوقف شغل على نفسي انا شغال على
نفسي كل يوم الحمد لله فانت تارك انه مجال
للاعمال انه حتى تكون خارجيه يعني طيب
نللي في احدث مقابلاتها قالت انك انت ممثل
كويس بس ما عندكش خبره كبيره لانه الخبره
من كثره الاعمال بتتفق معاها في هذا
الكلام ولا بتحس ان انتقدتك من تحت لتحت
احنا جايين احنا احنا فاعلين خير احنا
جايين نهدي النفوس يعني بس انه
تقول كده
طبعا ههه في كل الاحوال مش هتخلص
هي كده مش هتخلص وكده مش هتخلص فانا
رومانسي انا اكيد مش مش هقول ان انا يعني
اكتر واحد خبره في العالم بس الحمد لله
انا مذاكر واخد الموضوع عن الدراسه مش
واخده انا اللي داخل اخد لقطه ولا داخل
عشان خاطر اعمل شويه فلوس انا الحمد لله
عشت حياه عندي حياه كبيره جدا قبل كده كنت
نجم فيها حاجه ثانيه انا النهارده بعمل
حاجه هو انا عندي الطاقه دي جوايا وهي
طاقه التاثير في بني ادم بالايجاب سواء
كان هتضحكه او هتعيطوا هتعمل دراما هتعمل
اكشن هتعمل حاجه رومانس الكلام ده كله
بالنسبه لي لو انا قصرت في البني ادم انا
النهارده دي رسالتي فانا ما بشوفش اي حاجه
تانيه غير ان انا افضل اشتغل على نفسي
عشان اقدر اعمل ده يا هشام يا سؤال
اعتراضي كده
بتمرن بتمرن جامد جدا بقى لي حبه فعلا
وبعمل شويه تمارين وحاجات عشان لو حاجه
اكشن جايه الفتره الجايه لازم اكون جاهز
يعني لانه حسيت كده من وشك انك نازل نازل
وزنك كم كيلو نازل
فتره كنت نايم
بتهدي بس الحمد لله دلوقتي انا راجع تاني
يعني الحمد لله لا ممتاز ممتاز احنا طبعا
بنتمنى لك التوفيق وعارفين انه لسه عندك
كمان يعني نازله اعمال قادمه يعني ان شاء
الله حتحقق فيها المزيد من النجاح شكرا لك
يا هشام وان شاء الله دائما بالتوفيق
وسعيده انه نحن قابلناك وتعرفنا على روحك
الحلوه معانا هنا على الهواء
تسلم كل سنه وانتم طيب معنا من القاهره
الفنان هشام عاشور
[موسيقى]
يلا يا
ولد
[موسيقى]
سعودي في واحد
روح قول له يقول لك انا عمك انا عمه وتاج
راسي يوم الثلاثاء بكره الاربعاء ان شاء
الله عليك
دائما احب الازرع البسمه امام الكاميرا
معروف انا بعفاوي عفويتي المسلسل مثل ما
قلت من اولى حلقات مكسره الدنيا والناس
عبروا عن حبهم واشادوا بايداء او باداء
ابراهيم لدور ريان
مثل ما شفتوا كثار في التغريدات خلاص من
اول كم يوم حاسمين قراره مو شايفين
ابراهيم الحجاج الافضل في الموسم الرمضاني
وعاجبهم المسلسل جدا وهنا لازم نقول ان
الفتره الماضيه كانت فتره انتعاشة
لابراهيم بدءا من جائزه
والان اصداء منه ولدنا اثنين واللي معظمها
ارشادات وثناء عليه خليه ينضم الينا من
الخبر النجم ابراهيم الحجاج اهلا فيك معنا
ابراهيم وكل عام وانت بالف خير يا رب
السلام عليكم
يعطيك العافيه شكرا استضافه انا ما عندي
طاوله هنا احط عليها يدي بس اني بقص يدي
كذا
حسيتك ابراهيم
اللي قلناها عنك
صراحه خجلتي تواضعي
[ضحك]
ابراهيم خليني ابتدي معك اصلا انا يعني من
اول بدي اقول لك اياها لازم اعتذر لك في
العلن انا صراحه لما انت تتذكر وقت لما
ترشحت لي جائزه جوي قلت لك ما في امل تفوز
اه الجرح لسه موجود اوكي قلت لك ما في امل
تفوز لانه الاسماء اللي كانت معاك كمان
قويه جدا يعني الصراحه فقلت لك ما في امل
تفوز بعدين ما شاء الله عليك فزت فانا
اعتذر صراحه يعني ومبروك الجائزه
جميله يعطيك العافيه اولا شكرا لكل كانوا
صيني في جائزه جوي والبركه في الجميع
مبسوط اني فزت بفضل الله ثم الناس ثم
الفريق عمل ولدنا العظيم شكرا ساره انك
اعتذرتي قدام الناس والان نستودعكم الله
نشوفكم كفايه
خليني احط لك الصوره بالله حقه الجائزه
لما نمت مع وحطيتها جنبك يعني في السرير
فيها حركه ميسي يعني من قد ما انت ما انت
مصدق انك انت فزت بالجائزه يعني حتى انت
كمان كنت شاكك يا ابراهيم
يعني هو مشي جميل
ممكن تخاطر الافكار بيني وبينها بنفس طيب
من هو ولدنا يعني الجزء الاول
ما كان مخطط انه يكون في جزء ثاني صح بس
مع النجاح قررتوا انكم تعملوا جزء ثاني
والله الحمد لله يعني
كان في حوارات
اثناء عرض الجزء الاول مع الكاتب والمنتج
والمشرف العامل احنا نبدا نرتب جزء ثاني
والحمد لله هذا بفضل الله بفضل الناس جدا
سعيد ان احنا جالسين
جالسين
نعيش هذا العمل العظيم
مبسوط في بكل افراد احس اني بين عائلتي
والحمد لله ان شاء الله الجاي اجمل واجمل
والاحداث توها قاعد تسخن في العمل وان شاء
الله انها تنحرق مو تنحرق واو ساخنه فهمتي
انحرق اوكي طيب لانه صراحه نحن في الجزء
الاول قلنا يعني كيف حيعملوا جزء ثاني الا
رحتوا انتوا قلبتوا الامور كلها وطلعتوا
انه لا ممكن تكون في قصه ثانيه هل نتوقع
جزء ثالث
يا رب والله بالعكس امن جدك وين حتروح
الجزء الثالث
ارجع
ما
ادري والله هذا كله عند كاتبنا العظيم
مخرج يعني ان شاء الله ما أعرف الحين
الجزء الثاني نعرض ان شاء الله ونشوف كيف
قفلته الله يكتب الخير يا رب بس انت متابع
ردود الافعال يعني
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
لحظه لحظه من فضلك
تعمل معك لقاء وتتكلم عن قصه
خلاص قصتي قلتها لكن الناس فاضي انتوا اي
احد يجي يقول لكم مقابله تدخلونا تحكم احد
كبير تركي العجمي
داود شريان دخلوهم
طبعا انت قصدك كبير قدرا وقيمه
ايه طبعا انا والله الصراحه كان مكتوب في
النص انا مجبور اني التزم
يعني
اعظم مذيعه وكلنا نحبك ترى الله يخليك
تسلم انت منحاز ليا لانه احنا اصدقاء
فبتقول هذا الكلام باب الصداقه طبخ
طباختكم ادمان ترى
فضحتني طب خلاص ابراهيم
[ضحك]
بدي اكلمك كمان مو بس عن هذه الاشياء بدي
اكلمك عن ستار تجربه ستار يعني انت ممكن
انا عاصرت معاك قبل نزول ستار كيف كانت
عندك مشاعر خوف وترقب والكلام هذا كله ردت
الفعل او التعليقات حقت الناس كيف شفتها
لما نزل الفيلم
والله جدا يعني سعيد ان الحمد لله الى
اليوم في رمضان الفيلم لسه موجود في قاعه
السينما في جميع انحاء المملكه وايضا في
الدول الخليج جدا سعيد ان الفيلم لسه
جالسين الى الان عليه اقبال جميل الحمد
لله احنا اليوم المركز الثالث في تاريخ
الافلام السعوديه والعالميه والمحليه في
ترتيب
شباك تذاكر شكرا الشميسي فيلمز ابراهيم
خير الله عبد الله العراك النجوم اللي في
الفيلم على
تلفاز 11 شكرا
قريب لقلبي وجميل انه يعني الان من ولدنا
جالسين يعرض وفي السنه ايضا ستار موجود ما
عندي مشاعر والله تشرح وش ودي بس انا عندي
امنيه ان احنا نسوي جزء ثاني من العمل وان
شاء الله
انت اشتغلت كثير على موضوع الملاكمه انت
اصلا تحب الملاكمه اصلا
مصارعه حره عفوا كله بالنسبه لي ضرب
كل هذا ضارب ايش هذا
لا تتمسخر
[موسيقى]
شهرين انا جلست اتمرن شهر ونص تقريبا مع
سبيليو منظمه السعوديه مهتمه بالمصارعه
عذبتهم اول اسبوع لان انا اسوي الحركه
واحسن اني انا سويتها بسرعه بس يبدو لي هم
قاعد
بس ان شاء الله يعني ان شاء الله
مصارعه ومشرف
واستمريت بعدها ابراهيم ولا خلاص رجعت
لاسلوب حياتك القديم لا يتضمن اي نوع من
انواع الرياضه
الا العب العب بلاي ستيشن شوي يعني كلمت
الشباب في سبيليو قالوا لي لا يعني ما
ادري ليه قالوا لك ملك
والله معاهم حق صراحه يعني افهمهم انا طيب
الفتره يعني احنا بنقول احنا ما شاء الله
2023 سنتك ما شاء الله ايش مخبي لنا في
الفتره الجايه
والله يا رب يعني يا رب تكون يعني سنه خير
علينا جميعا
في مشروع فيلم جالس ينطبخ على البطيء ويا
رب ان شاء الله انه يرى النور نهايه السنه
مختلف حيكون
يكون يا ابراهيم
لا
لا ابدا مالي فيها
ضحك بس
بدي اقول لك حاجه متى حنشوفك عريس ان شاء
الله لو حتصير عامل زي ريان مع فيروز في
المسلسل في من هو ولدنا
والله
[تصفيق]
في موضوع حساس شوي الله يكتب الخير يا رب
ان شاء الله توني صغيره انا ان شاء الله
اذا بعدين نتزوج يا رب
[ضحك]
ان شاء الله يا رب دعواتك ادعي لنا ان شاء
الله الله يرزقنا الزواج قسمه ونصيب ايوه
لا انت ارتبك بس احنا شايفينك بتعذب فيروز
في المسلسل فنشوف قدي ايش القصه الموضوع
هذا قريب من شخصيتك الحقيقيه
ظهر هذا تمثيل انا في الحقيقه رومانسي كفو
ونشمي كريم شاب يعني حلو وسيم من الجهتين
ابين وسيم
يعني طيب ابراهيم انا مره بتمنى لك
التوفيق دايما في كل شيء انت تعرف انه
يعني انت يعني صديق عزيز على قلبي يعني
وموهوب جدا
الله يخليك ابراهيم انت من اول هالكنا على
انه عندك موعد عندك موعد تبي تخلص ايش
الموعد
والله عندي سحور جماعي هذه كلها عشان تروح
تاكل
اليوم
يعني ما اعرف ايش اقول بعد كذا خلاص
الشباب مهم طيب هذه اولويات الشباب شكرا
لك يا ابراهيم لا لسه بدري
شكرا لك كان معنا ابراهيم الحج شكرا
الفنان محمد فؤاد من امس متصدر الترند
والمنصات من بعد ما كان ضيف برنامج
المقالب لرمز جلال اللي بيعرض في هذا
الموسم رامز نيفر اند سببه مو المقلب
وانما صحه محمد فؤاد اللي اقلقت اكثر من
بعد المقلب لانه كان قال في بدايه الحلقه
انه هو عمل عمليه تكميم معدن 15 يوم
المقلب كان داخل غرفه الغساله اللي بس
دخلها محمد فؤاد بدات دوران والخطخه وكانه
داخل الغساله الرسمي المقلب انتهى بمحمد
فؤاد على الارض وهو بيتفقد الجرح اللي
يبدو انه انتهى بنزيف كمان
الناس من بعد المقلب تداولت مقاطع مقلب
وصور منه كثار ومنهم محبين الفنان وصفحات
فانزلو هاجمت رامز باشد العبارات واعتبروا
اللي صار غير انساني ومن بينهم الغاضبين
ومن بين الغاضبين والمهاجمين كان في طبيب
محمد فؤاد الدكتور اسامه طه اللي نشر بوست
على صفحته على فيسبوك ووصف اللي صار
بالخطير وجريمه شنعاء من الممكن انه يخسر
محمد فؤاد حياته لانه العمليه اللي عاملها
عمليه تصحيح لعمليه قبلها من عشر سنوات
وبتتطلب حذر في التعامل مع الجرح وقال نصا
كيف تدنى الاخلاص لمستوى اللام مسؤوليه في
عفوا كيف تدنى الاخلاق لمستوى المسؤوليه
في سبيل اسعاد جمهور ليس سعيدا بما حدث
وقال انه بيحمل البرنامج كامل المسؤوليه
في حال صار اي شيء ولكن الناس تفاجات ان
البوست مع الموجود على الصفحه وضح الدكتور
السبب في تصريح اعلامي انه حول البوست
للاصدقاء فقط لانه طبيب وما بحب الدوشه
وشاف الناس بتتكلم عن محمد فؤاد بطريقه مو
لائقه وانه محمد فؤاد اتصل فيه وقال له
انه هو بخير وصحه جيده
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم
انا عود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]